à cette nouvelle instruction seuls deux
accusés sont présents dans la bourse
critiqué de cette cour d'assises un
troisième homme de 38 ans précieusement
impliqué dans cette fusillade du reste
on le togo à sainte anne le 13 janvier
2014 est en cavale
certaines personnes ont été
effectivement jugés en correctionnelle
puisqu'elles n'ont été poursuivis que
pour des ports d'armes
parce qu'il faut savoir que durant cette
soirée il y avait de nombreuses
personnes armées mais toutes n'ont pas
fait usage de leurs armes et a
effectivement elles n'avaient pas leur
place ces personnes n'a en cour
d'assises
maintenant on y est dont on est au tout
début on va voir comment vont se
dérouler les débats et on espère que ça
puisse se dérouler en sérénité et qu'on
puisse approcher au moins de la vérité
ne serait ce que pour les familles un
début d'audience tout de même perturbé
par la présence des accusés dans ce box
vitré comme l'ensemble des avocats du
board martinique ceux de la défense et
de la partie civile tente de s'y opposer
encore aujourd'hui le barreau a dès le
début dès que nous avons découvert cette
construction clandestine fait pendant un
week-end n'est pas un box dans une cage
il ya même du fil de fer
le barreau est contre on estime que
c'est une atteinte à la présomption
d'innocence à la dignité que ce
traitement inhumain et dégradant et que
ça pose un problème de confidentialité
entre l'avocat et les son client
finalement à l'issue d'une brève
suspension d'audience la présidente
optera pour un match et des accusés dans
ce box mais elles sont tout de même
interrogé
au fil des audiences à la barre de cette
cour d'assises aux vertus des débats aux
environs de 11h à l'issue de rappel des
faits place aux enquêteurs et aux
différents témoins un officier de police
judiciaire déclare que les constatations
matérielles réalisées au restaurant met
en évidence que les faits se sont
déroulés à plusieurs endroits distincts
à l'intérieur mais aussi aux abords de
l'établissement aux deux hommes ont été
froidement abattus
grâce à des caméras de
vidéosurveillance on a pu essayer
d'entrevoir un peu les les
positionnements
les comportements de certains mais pas
de tout le monde dans ce dossier où ils
montent beaucoup de monde autant sur le
banc des accusés que parmi les experts
barbie les témoins on va avoir beaucoup
de visioconférence ce qui sur un procès
d'une semaine
aussi complexe est une difficulté dans
l'après-midi place aux témoins si les
responsables la sécurité ainsi qu'un
policier de la paf ont assisté aux
différentes scènes de violence cependant
ils ne peuvent donner des précisions
permettant d'identifier les tireurs
demain seconde journée d'audience
place aux enquêtes de personnalité